[Music]
it's the clean vibes kit from the honest
company
that's jessica alba who i did never been
kissed with
um this is her brand i think everybody
on the planet knows what it is and the
reason everybody on the planet knows
what it is is because she cares about
the planet
so these cleaning products basically so
what you do ross is you get these
refills okay
you pop them open and then you put the
refill
inside the bottle and you put your water
in there
and you spray and clean and this
will avoid so much
plastic when i look at water bottles now
i just have
anxiety and it is time for us to step it
up
and change our habits you think about
how many of these you have thrown away
in your life
right now what she's done is made it
where we could reuse this over and over
and over again
i'm not smart honest company it's just
it's so she just did everything right
and she has our back and she has the
planets back and it comes with a
bathroom
a multi-service and glass cleaners and
it's
39.99 for the set and then you get your
refill
it's the idesign divided lazy susan it's
29.99 for all that organizing power
and it's your classic lazy susan 360
flexibility plus you can customize your
sections
and there's even a removable bin
i love this and when i was thinking
about which room i would put this in you
know because you could do office of
course i go to snacks i put snacks in it
but you know when the spices are in the
little cupboard and you can't see the
ones in the back imagine if they were in
this
and you could just spin i think i might
have to um
follow monica i want to put this in my
refrigerator
oh my god i didn't even think about that
you could put cheeses in it and just
spin
cheddar gouda i mean i just want to take
this home and
and i'm going to start in my fridge and
then i'll uh
i'll report back okay you take that one
home but i'm taking this one
well let's see what each of us does with
them and compare
let's report back it's the news you want
to know